die Sache ist ich werde gleich einen
prank machen aber das erst am Ende dass
ich mir ein Bedrock hole ein Blog über
den Creative Mode und sagen sie kriegt
1.000 Euro wenn Sie das Ding abbaut
hey Leute ich finde es unter dem Aspekt
Locke nichts Sandra was
antreten was
[Musik]
ja warum ist der Holzblock schief
schon wieder scheiße gebaut ich muss mir
eine Glocke holen ich fahre mit ich habe
das Dinge repariert ich werde dich jetzt
mal beobachten soll ich eigentlich im
letzten Stream schon machen dann kam
dieser Serie ja ja
das Boot du hast doch ein Boot
ich habe kein Boot ich habe doch gesagt
gib mir dein Boot ich habe doch keins
das war doch Weg im letzten Stream aber
bei mir doch auch oh nein
[Musik]
ist auch keine Truhe
oh mein Gott ich habe ein Schiff
gefunden
boah gute Sachen hier drin nice
irgendwie wisst ihr was ganz komisch ist
Leute
immer soll ich dir mal sagen Luca was
ich ganz komisch finde
was
auch unter Wasser
sind weg
[Musik]
kurz bei dir ein wir haben nämlich eine
Mission
wir haben der Schatzkarte
genau da lang fahren wir dahin
[Musik]
genau im Berg ach der kann natürlich
auch da oben sein ne müsste der hier
irgendwo sein
[Musik]
hier oben drauf einfach
drauf gekommen
[Musik]
okay ich baue mich jetzt ganz hoch Laser
ne ein paar Sekunden später
[Musik]
als die anderen kann das sein
Wasser immer nach unten okay ich weiß
wie ich das schon mache du weißt wie du
von da oben runter springst und ich
stirbst ja okay
[Musik]
mega cool wollen wir uns mal für zu
Hause sonst Sprungturm bauen
ja guck mal wie hoch ne wollen wir uns
ins Schwimmbad bauen
[Musik]
verstanden
die Haustür machen
so jetzt gegen Ende des Streams ne ich
habe dich übrigens geprankt du musst nur
herausfinden was der prank ist du hast
mich in Minecraft geprankt ja und ich
habe es auch nicht bemerkt in den
anderthalb Stunden nehmen wir schon
Minecraft spielen ja was ist denn das
für ein beschissener prank dann ja
irgendwie hat er nicht so funktioniert
das dass die auch einfach erstmal hat
die so ein schlechten prank vorbereitet
den man einfach nicht merkt und zweitens
ist es einfach auch noch ein prank wo
sie jetzt nicht mal sagt ja guck mal das
ist der und der prank sondern auch noch
dieses ich soll es rausfinden unbedingt
ich habe zum Ende noch eine Aufgabe für
dich
welche
möchtest du noch mal ein Schatz suchen
ja
okay möchtest du denn diesmal alleine
suchen okay weil ich habe noch eine
Schatzkarte sagt das machen wir nächstes
Mal kannst du das mal eben kurz machen
dann mache ich ein bisschen Insel
Reparatur
[Musik]
gefunden du musst wahrscheinlich mit dem
Boot erstmal in die Richtung fahren wo
wir hingefahren sind nach dahinten das
Boot steht ja noch da unten nur wenige
Minuten später was ist denn
[Musik]
was ist denn mit der Schatzkarte mann ey
was ist
was
[Musik]
schon gefunden
das noch mal kurz schlafen gehen dann
zeige ich dir zum Ende noch mal kurz
deine Aufgabe wo du heute tausend Euro
gewinnen kannst jetzt in die kriegen
weil es nicht geht und zwar
habe ich
in einer unserer Kisten gefunden die hat
wahrscheinlich der Ultimate Venom
gedroppt
einen Block der relativ lange dauert ihn
abzubauen
und man muss sie mit einem besonderen
Werkzeug abbauen ja wenn du das
hinkriegst das herauszufinden und den
Block abzubauen ey hör auf mich jetzt zu
schlagen
ja Holzschaufel
ich setze ihn in dein Haus okay hier
dann kannst
[Musik]
ist
zweiter sind die Jahre später
[Musik]
was ist was war los warum hast du dein
Haus in die Luft gesprengt 1000 Euro ich
habe doch gesagt wie du das Ding abbauen
ich bin raus
bitte einfach nur sauer ich bin so sauer
nein
ja es war ein prank mit dem mit dem
Bedrock aber guck mal das sind doch
meine pranks das ist einfach nur lustig
wir hätten den ja easy wieder wegmachen
können im Creative Mode wisst ihr aber
sie hat es selbst in die Luft gesprungen
sie muss doch auf die Idee kommen dass
das ihr Haus in die Luft sprengt keine
Ahnung was ihr prank war wisst ihr es
hat sich im Stream gemacht was war ihr
prank das will ich wissen Sandra prank
sie hat Sachen aus dem Inventar überall
verteilt sie hat Blöcke im Wald im Wald
geh in den Wald sandra hat im Wald
irgendwie ein prank gemacht oder was in
welchem Wald aber nicht hier sondern da
hinten wahrscheinlich nicht dabei ist
das ihr ernst
das hier war ihr prank
dass die ein paar Blöcke hier in den in
die Pampa setzt also sorry Marvin und
Kelvin machen bessere pranks als Sandra
ne
mein beileid an der Stelle bin ich auch
raus ey das ist ja traurig dass die das
als prank betitelt
[Musik]